hey we're back
no no no no stop
it eats into my time
npr hosts prattle while their employees
tattle
yeah public radio loves snitches like
their tote bags love stitches
npr is encouraging employees to rat each
other out if they don't comply with the
company's mask policy in the office this
is according to an npr memo obtained by
the new york post owned by our parent
company crisco
the memo reads quote if you notice
someone who has forgotten their mask you
might tell them
hey you forgot your mask
now in the same world you might respond
hey you forgot to shut the hell up
but this is crazy times the memo added
that employees could let a superior know
so they can remind that person or get hr
involved and repeat offenders could be
fired just following orders folks
now all this is doubly nuts considering
dc where npr's headquartered dropped
indoor mask mandates for stores and
restaurants back in march but if npr did
what people liked
they wouldn't have to beg for donations
and the memo yeah screw them
the memo also claims that employees
caught unmasked should say thank you for
the reminder that they're violating the
rule
and then you bend over
there's even a system where employees
can anonymously snitch on each other you
got to hand it to npr though they're not
asking employees to do something they
wouldn't expect their listeners to do
so for all of us at npr this concludes
our broadcast day remember to mask up
and mask often
ma'am stay back and put on your mask
we're a hundred feet away from each
other and we're outside now come on
let's go we have dinner reservations
have i married this [ __ ]
come on
put some pep in your step
pretend like it's sunday night football
with all the boys you're trying to get
there faster i'm so sick i don't think
you wear a mask for that
you know npr never talks back to me
[Applause]
hi
i don't know where to go with this i
feel like a hypocrite right because like
we're ragging on npr but
this place is crazy too
i mean i mean
you don't even have to have kovid and
they'll send you home you know but
anyway i digress yeah i mean you might
have coveted
at any time yes so you should just stay
home all the time
just stay home in case you have covered
and but it's because it's ugh are people
snitching on other people i don't know i
know what is this i don't know i think
it's like covid is like the new herpes
where the stigma is worse than what it
actually is yes
i wouldn't having to tell people yes
exactly you know this is like it would
be really cool to be an undercover like
in 21 jump street
right but your oh your only role is to
catch people without their masks try you
try to entrap them by getting them to
take off their mask
right but then you'd have to be at npr
all day which doesn't sound fun at all
yes what does it stand for
uh not particularly
reasonable reasonable hey not bad
i love that they had the memo it
suggested passive aggressive behavior
right
they suggested you could go up to them
and say i think you forgot your mask
that's the way they would deal it i used
to listen to npr and i feel bad for them
because i like them because they talk so
quiet i like that too i used to turn on
my radio in my car and i would listen to
the quiet talking people but now it's
such a parody of itself
i still flip it on occasionally in the
car and they're like
are hurricanes racist yeah
and the answer is always yes
yes but they say we'll be right back
after this with a professor listen to 10
seconds of jazz
it's true though i mean it turns out
katie that the people with the softest
voices have the hardest hearts yeah it's
true it's amazing that these people get
your tax money yeah stuff like that they
don't get that much though do that they
get enough yeah they gotta take the
money i'll take the tax money back yeah
yeah yeah the npr tax cut oh look there
are a lot of things that you can that we
should have a list for to snitch on in
the office like if you bring fish to the
office
uh if you burn popcorn in the office
there's a whole list of things that
there should you should be allowed to
snitch about and talk to hr about this
is not one of them yeah there are things
that are done in our bathrooms that like
yes exactly
that's fine it actually defies any kind
of human explanation it's like a bird
came in
[Laughter]
there are hula-hooping
[Laughter]
and i
[Applause]
laughing at batman
everybody seems to know what i mean
more like hula pooping yes
yeah i know i know i basically just
screwed that thing up adam last word to
you i think we have time for last word
what do you uh do do you think that this
will ever go away
no and i think at some places it won't
like npr i feel like right now it's
clearly no longer about science or
keeping people healthy it's about
feeling better than other people it's
about making yourself feel superior
which is also i think why people listen
to npr in the first place yeah they want
to just feel superior to other people
yeah it does makes it's like it's like
the official station i hate to call them
karen's because i always feel bad for a
woman named karen
are there any women here named karen
screw the karen's uh
nbr is the official station for karen's
right which we used to usually call the
no the nosy neighbors the next door
neighbor and bewitched remember her
gladys yeah
yeah thank you get that man out of here
i have a term but um
yeah but that's what it is it's like
that's what the station is that's their
brand okay i'm going to shut up now
up next does identifying as a lady make
a criminal smart or shady
yes
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else